[Music]
okay so I just finished my
40 minutes at the gym now I end the gym
with five minutes stairs and I don't
have a stair machine uh the gym here
doesn't have one so I just go to my
building stairs and then put on a five
minute timer and go up and down the
stairs as much as I can for those five
minutes so
let's do it all right
before moving on I wanted to thank the
sponsors of this video monday.com
monday.com is an amazing tool for people
looking to just better manage their days
especially if your days are revolved
around different spaces so work then
personal life then personal projects
they have amazing Integrations with
tools like Gmail MailChimp and even
GitHub so you can go from the office
where you're being this badass developer
to now managing that newsletter viewers
that you created for community and then
going on to managing that personal life
of yours through Gmail with both a
mobile and desktop version you're able
to keep track of your day quite
seamlessly I've used monday.com long
before this partnership even happened so
I'm very grateful it happened because I
sincerely can say that it is an amazing
tool and amazing platform and super easy
to use so definitely check them out if
you have any questions or would like to
learn more their information is in the
description box below okay back to the
video okay so that was my out I got
ready real quick because we're gonna
head over to Williamsburg to do some
shopping I'm so excited for the Barbie
movie let me know if y'all are headed to
that sometime either the day of Premiere
or later on but I want an outfit for it
because I do the most so I'm gonna go
over and do some shopping so let's see
what we can find
[Music]
thank you
I am hungry as
so let's get some food
okay I really really love this place
they have in my opinion the best Curry
ever in Day Good Karma so yeah let's go
why don't you use this time shopping to
talk about work as you see from the
title I am no longer working as a
software engineer for the company I was
before this decision did not come easy
and it came after multiple interactions
with just less than preferred
experiences and treatment overall when
it comes to the humongous corporate
machine I was part of it just didn't
feel good being being in that and
contributing to their goals in that way
and so I decided to take a step back and
move on to different things better
things I asked that yes we continue to
be an amazing community that has kind
motivating and um yeah just cheering
each other on so yeah anyway
[Music]
God we're home okay
oh I'm exhausted I am
exhausted Hi how are you you're good
you're good okay so we are home I am
exhausted may not look like a lot of
shopping maybe it does but oh my
goodness I feel like I have been out
eight hours just going up and down
blocks with bags and everything so I am
very excited to be home I'm seriously
she's just gonna do like
be here with my AC for a second
oh my
God
okay
I have changed I could not live like
that any longer but so my birthday was
what oh exactly a week ago oh wow I've
been 25 for seven days that's fun oh my
birthday was a week ago and my best
friends in the entire world thank you
Abby michaelen sent me a little care
patch package so I really wanted to
unbox it with y'all so let's see what we
have the blanket right off the bat oh my
goodness
it's actually like
this is really soft it's all strawberry
and okay this is cute because it's a
company with this strawberry cushion
this is strawberry right yeah
I think what you're letting put up to
the camera I think I'm like confused
because like
I feel like strawberries have like
like it feels like dust and seeds and
everything I'm like confused as like why
not once one side okay
so we have a lot let me
so we have
a handle from where's it from I don't
know where it's from but it's aloe and
Bergamot is that how you say that Allen
birthmark next
that is really cute hair clip it's
grapes do y'all see that it's all
it's Grace right
are these grapes
I don't know I I like thinking of them
as grapes especially because of the
color
there's
there are some
face masks oh okay this isn't a face
like this goes inside the bag for a nice
and moisturizing bad and then we have a
sheet mask so it's a whole
spot
10 to 20 minutes okay okay I did a mask
okay so I said yesterday as well as a
whole something that I was having and I
was really disappointed because you only
put the mask on for five minutes and I'm
a person who likes to keep it sitting
there like I'll sleep with a mask
and then okay first okay before I even
open this
so it says olive oil soap rolls do you
see this
a little
house
and we have we have a nice big book okay
it says did you hear about Kitty Carr a
novel by Crystal Smith Paul I'm getting
um
I'm getting an old Hollywood
from this
if you guys saw the card that I'm
looking at right now this is the most
precious card oh my goodness look
it's it's a pig being flown
I like butterflies oh my goodness
that's really funny
I like this a lot this is really
really I'm honestly really
I'm very very well so yeah I'm gonna
read this
but oh my goodness thank you guys I'm
really excited oh my goodness I feel so
loved I'm really excited let me put
these back but yeah that one's
the last little bit of um like my
birthday stuff I
there's really nothing else because I
spent my birthday in Manhattan last week
and that was really fun so yeah it was
a day and a half y'all I am tired
um I think I am going to call it
please let me know who is going to see
the bar movie who it has
um we just say hi so no thank you all
for joining me and I hope you have a
fantastic night bye all